[Music]
go on admit it you still miss The
Descendants franchise we hear you and
that's why we're beyond pumped that
dissonance for could well be on the
cards the Disney Channel original movie
has been part of our lives since 2015
and we'd love to keep it going three
movies just aren't enough although the
cast originally said that descendants
three was the end of the story they
seemed to be changing their tune in 2020
we've got the latest revelations from
the stars about what's happening behind
the scenes for the next step discover
how tough Camryn sophia carson and
mitchell hope have dished out continuing
the descendant story i guess i would say
whether that goes on without us I don't
know you know I mean like it could be
anything I just think it's a big world
all hail King Ben we're doing our best
curtsies to the ruler of auradon and the
Isle of the Lost as he's given us the
latest glimmer of hope that dissonance
for could happen when j14 asked Mitchell
hope if there's a possibility Disney
will make a fourth movie he gushed about
what a great franchise it is and how it
was a lot of fun to be part of that
experience he admitted that he doesn't
know any details yet and hasn't heard
anything concrete but he teased that
there's always a chance on the horizon
so if Disney came a-callin at Mitchell's
door the actor would totally be up for
it
he revealed he'd be excited to do it
because he just loves playing Ben that's
because mouths Bay is such a pure
benevolent character Mitchell gave us an
insight into the acting process too he
dished that when he plays the character
he starts subconsciously adopting a few
of that characters traits and that
changes his own behavior given that Ben
is such a sweetheart it's no wonder that
Mitchell would always feel nice when he
stepped into those shoes did you love
King Vin too
when we think of another descendants
movie we envision the story continuing
for the characters we already know and
love but rather than catching up with
everyone what if it was a spinoff
focusing on a specific couple we'd love
to see how mal and Ben's life panned out
after the barrier to the Isle came down
there's still plenty to explore there
like the possible tension between the
king and queen of our Dawn's different
styles of ruling and of course the
possibility of them have an adorable
minimis we would be beyond excited for a
fourth movie but we'd also love to see
the characters again in any format
possible are there other opportunities
to continue The Descendants story
outside of the silver screen
that's where Sophia Carson comes in in
June 2020 Sophia Carson gave us all hope
that she'll return as Evie but not
necessarily on the big screen we're
talking Broadway instead let's rewind to
the start of the story when it was
revealed that a stage adaptation of the
three movies had been written
it's called descendants the musical and
it's been created by music theatre
international in partnership with Disney
theatrical productions this theatrical
version is based on the trilogy of films
and it became available for licensing in
March 2020 which means it to be heading
to Broadway in the not-too-distant
future but what has this got to do with
Sofia
well when j14 asks her if she wanted to
reclaim her role as Evie on Broadway
Sofia replied absolutely it would be
such a privilege to be able to continue
that journey
Evie gave me so much she's just this
gift that keeps on giving she brings so
much joy to my life so I would love to
Sofia also revealed that being on
Broadway was actually part of the career
plan she mapped out when she was a
little kid she dished when I was 10
years old I had a school project where
we had to write a timeline of what we
wanted to be when we grew up
I drew like a stage and I wrote my
timeline and it was like I'm going to be
a pop star and a movie star then I'm
going to take a break and I'm going to
Broadway I'm going to have a few years
on Broadway and then I'm going to have
my comeback like Cher just imagine if
dove Cameron and some of the other
original cast members also got involved
seeing them perform live on stage as the
characters we know and love would be
next level the show would surely sell
out every performance as fans flocked to
the theater to see their favorite stars
it would be like going to their concerts
only better make it happen Sofia Sofia
also dished in April 2020 on
Zach sang shows that the movies could
continue to she started off by
reminiscing about how the whole
experience was magical from start to
finish
and even a year on from the release of
the third movie Sofia still feels that
the franchise is more and more loved
every single day as for her role in the
movie trilogy the actor said it's one of
the greatest honors of my life to play
Eevee and to be part of this franchise
we had this privilege of touching
hundreds of millions of kids and they
all get to be part of Disney history
they'll forever be part of the fairy
tale when asked if there's more of the
story to be told Sophia said it's such a
big universe this could go on forever
there's so many descendants of
descendants for focus on new characters
who would you like to see would you want
to learn more about Cecilia Faso the air
dizzy Jermaine or the Smee twins after
all they didn't get a huge amount of
screen time in d3 so there's definitely
more to tell there or would you rather
move on to the next generation we're
talking mal and Ben's kids Plus Evie and
Doug's children and Carlos and Jane's
offspring we want to see the next
generation folks too but of course we
wouldn't be able to see Cameron voice as
Carlos as the actor tragically passed
away in July 2019 Sofia isn't sure about
the original cast returning either she
added as far as the original descendants
I don't know if there's more for us it's
really hard to imagine doing anything
about Cameron so for us that's where our
heart lives but it's opened to so much
imagination but as far as doing it with
Cameron boys playing Carlos Sofia added
that she can't even think about it as a
thought is too difficult she lived life
with deaf Cameron is also spoken about
what the future of descendants could
look like without Cameron voice and how
the story could continue with the next
generation of vks and a case in October
2019
dub spoke with Yahoo about how she feels
when she watches the third movie she
revealed it feels like Cameron is still
there when you watch it it wasn't as
painful as we thought
so perhaps by doing more in the
franchise together the stars could keep
Cameron's memory with them I mean first
of all it feels like Cameron's still
here when you watch it
she's definitely conflicted about it
though speaking about Cameron's passing
dealt old Hollywood Life that what
happened to Cameron was so incredibly
heart-wrenching for all of them and it's
something they could never recover from
that makes the idea of making another
movie a really difficult concept daph
can see now on the one hand it would be
nostalgic for them all and it would be
healing in a lot of ways but it might
also be super wrong and there's always a
concern that it could go either way
that's why it's been impossible for the
cast to give a definite answer about the
future of the franchise as dub says it
would depend on how they were all
feeling about the situation she's
grateful for how Disney created a safe
space for the cast to be wherever
they're at the studio didn't force any
promo commitments on any of them in fact
Disney cancelled everything when Cameron
passed stuff feels confident that Disney
wants what's in the cast's best
interests so that means it's a waiting
game although she was doubtful about
future installments at that specific
time she was also open to the
possibility saying we'll see although
understandably unsure it seems like dub
is definitely becoming more open to the
idea of more descendants movies when
Entertainment Tonight asked her whether
or not fan to look forward to a fourth
movie dev revealed I do think there's a
world where where that happens I don't
know anything for sure she added I don't
love the idea of doing it without
Cameron I don't know what the plot would
be and I don't know what it would be
like but I also love the franchise and I
love Kenny and I love Disney and I love
the cast I love that time in my life
even though it would likely have to
change significantly there's a chance
that the franchise continues on in a
different incarnation dov added there is
nothing that I can say for sure but I
definitely can say that it's not out of
the question as we've already heard
Sofia also believes in the possibility
of The Descendants universe continuing
but would you want to watch a fourth
movie if it didn't start of Sofia and
the main stars of their original films
for some fans it wouldn't be descendants
without them but for other fans it's all
about getting back into that world in
whatever way that's possible what about
if the BK's parents returned descendants
four could be a prequel showing us what
life was like for the villains on the
Isle of lost before they had kids we'd
love to discover more about Maleficent
and Hades relationship after all mouths
mom and dad are fascinating characters
in their own right
they've also had something to say about
that she revealed that other actors want
their franchise to continue specifically
the actors that played her parents
dub reveals the Digital Spy that she
knows Kristin Chenoweth who plays
Maleficent would love to be involved in
the
Chai's more dove dish that kristin is a
very good friend of hers and she knows
that kristin enjoys the franchise so
much as well as Cheyenne Jackson who
plays Hades dogs even went so far as to
reveal that there's definitely
possibility for that in the future would
you be interested in a dissonance movie
about the parents
when asked if she felt their third movie
was the end of descendants or if there
could be spin-offs and it could carry on
in different forms in the future dev had
a similar view to Sofia she revealed
that it would be smart for Disney to
capitalize on the brand that they
created but what specific direction does
Dov think they should choose well doves
offer a spin-off with a younger
characters we're assuming she means
dizzy and Celia Plus squeaky and squirmy
Smee she was quick to point out that she
hadn't heard anything about it
it's just that dove knows that Disney
has been very specific about saying that
this world doesn't really ever end it
goes on forever and the possibilities
are endless excitedly dove added that
she may or may not have heard about
something that she might be doing
involving the franchise what do you
think that could be although she would
never say that it's over dev would also
never confirm anything at that time but
she did confirmed that she would be open
to doing more Oh dove stop teasing us
and tell us already I can't I can't say
too much about it right now but I'm
really happy about it how would you like
the franchise to continue it's a
Broadway musical with some of the
original casts your favorite dream or do
you want a fourth movie featuring the
next generation or a prequel starring
the parents in their younger years sound
off in the comments and be sure to hit
that subscribe button for more videos
like this on the things thanks for
watching